foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
[Music]
[Music]
United States thank you very much
elements of bathrooms if you're just
joining us Rudy Giuliani is sweating his
face off explaining to us why Trump
really won the election again inspectors
every state
almost every approve this
is thrown away gone for eternity is this
a skit the only thing left is to prevent
a dead person that could have been not
filled out properly wait he's saying
there was a dead person in the envelope
Rudy is about to have actual drops of
sweat coming off of his brow I mean is
this a normal amount I don't know how
hot it is in the room but this something
seems very wrong here we'll be in the
lawsuit that comes out dude he's melting
Arizona is a state that we're looking at
very very carefully strongly looking at
it I would say we're probably I assume
oh my God she's working but she's
working for this
I'd like to read them all to you but I
don't have the time you should have had
the time and energy to go look for them
that's your job
like it's my job to defend the president
and represent the president Michigan
Wisconsin is he bleeding did you see is
he bleeding from his ear what on Earth
[Music]
is that hair dye is to look at the
lawsuits in order to do it it looks like
blood but in the material oh my God it's
everywhere
thousand at least and we're getting he's
gotta get off the stage and there are
other aspects of this fraud on the
morning of November someone's got to get
him a napkin they were going to count
the these this new kind of stuff I've
never seen anything like this what on
Earth it's getting onto his shirt now
Michigan and in Wisconsin any jury would
accept because they heard this evidence
that somebody had this plan
maybe that was always the plan
it looks like sap from an oak tree or a
maple tree it looks like someone's
making syrup to the city describe that
to you oh my God it's all over his face
I don't know guys it's sounding like
Trump won isn't it based on this side
[Music]
that that's that that dude he is gone
ladies and gentlemen Alex Jones is now
very very upset with me look at that
that is a freaking prefer director right
there he thinks he's smarter than you
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you Pac-Man never talked to the new
award because Pac-Man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true I'm not a knight
at the round that that actually is
accurate that dude is gone
dad is telling my children who not to be
it's hurt
the door scratching so open the door
prepare to meet your destiny
that is a freaking prefer right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
she's better than you and he's gonna
beat you
mangoes my bags of mangoes
I love mangoes too
nonsense okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime my bag of mangoes now costs
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes like
a free box seat that's it eight or
eleven bucks
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we are on a
very special day today is the last uh
press briefing for Joe Biden's White
House Press Secretary Jen saki I don't
believe she's officially announced where
she's going although the rumor is that
she's going to
who is that oh I shaved oh my God I
almost I barely even recognized who was
hosting today I just looked up at the at
the Monitor and I was like who the hell
is that
um I don't know that she's officially
announced where she's going but I guess
she's going to MSNBC is what the kids
are saying
um so that's going on she'll be replaced
by the deputy White House Press
Secretary Karine Jean-Pierre and uh
everybody's angry about everything I
mean just every people are angry that
she didn't stay long enough and the
person who's replacing her is a lesbian
and uh that's uh it's identity politics
and you know it's it's all crazy what's
going on right now
um now many of you have asked me from
the standpoint of tomorrow's Trump rally
will I be streaming it I actually will
not and it turns out tomorrow's Trump
rally I guess isn't really a rally
Trump's going to be in Austin Texas
tomorrow
and he's speaking at an event that you
have to pay to go to and it also I guess
he's speaking at like four o'clock
Central five eastern and so we are going
to have a correspondent on the ground
talking to people as they go into the
event so we'll have those clips for you
on Monday Tuesday if everything goes
well that's going to be great but I
guess the event itself is not expected
to be streamed live and also I am not
available at that time I'm going to be
uh I'm going to be partaking in high tea
in Manhattan or as some people pronounce
it Manhattan I know a couple people that
say Manhattan it's not my thing
personally but you know anyway so but it
doesn't matter that I have something to
do because it's not being streamed
apparently uh it's just like a donor
event and you know it's all sort of uh
crazy crazy stuff so we will have the
clips from the trumpists outside the
event for you hopefully Monday
maybe Tuesday
um and that's what's going on there now
I uh oh thanks to kurakaj Tool moo Jen
here weather boxer zero cool
and Rose Cassandra for the twitch Prime
subscriptions I appreciate that kicking
us up to six right away I will open
phone lines today if we get to a hundred
I actually have time today
um so that's just a I don't have to do
it but if people want it done I I am
able and willing to open phone lines if
we get to a hundred today oh thanks to
Sam the sleaze bag as well that's not
that's not my name for Sam that's just
his username Sam the sleaze bag uh and
we have a super chat
from Dustin who says David you look like
a 20 year old good jeans yeah I don't
know do I look younger with or without
the beard
thanks to Ryan Rincon new member number
eight I like there's not nothing in
particular is going on I just find that
every once in a while it's good to start
from scratch and then also if there's
any ingrown hair it'll be evident when
you do a full shave
and so uh it's just useful get
everything cleaned up and you know it's
just it's a whole thing it's a whole
thing that goes on I can't even really
go into it many of you actually one guy
in YouTube chat was incessantly trolling
David are you gonna talk about 2 000
mules David are you going to talk about
2 000 mules
2 000 mules is this new Dinesh D'Souza I
can't call it a documentary because it
doesn't document anything real
I would call it it's a new assembly of
audio visual files I don't even know
what else to call it and um it's
completely idiotic I what I'm willing to
do if you will allow it is we'll look at
the trailer then I'll tell you why the
thesis of the movie is Pond scum gutter
trash and then we can all move on and
never speak of it again okay let's look
at the uh let's look at the thing the
2020 election was the most secure in U.S
history
there has been no evidence of widespread
voter fraud
parents care election
most secure election in American history
really
all those of you volunteered and worked
the polls
deserve a special thanks okay notice
that
that guy put two ballots in okay it's
edited to maybe look like it was three
he put two ballots and for all we know
that's that guy in his partner's ballots
there's nothing illegal there's nothing
concerning about that video from the
entire nation
now this is the key frame right here
using cell phone Geo tracking and I'll
get back to that in a moment
this one mule made 53 trips to 20 drop
boxes
he's not alone
we tracked 2 000 mules making multiple
ballot drops
okay it's so stupid I can't even get
through all 94 seconds of it here's the
premise of this film okay the premise of
the film is
using cell phone geolocation data which
they they say they obtained and mapping
the geolocation data against ballot
dropboxes Dinesh D'Souza claims that he
has identified a ballot trafficking
that's a made-up term a ballot
trafficking conspiracy involving mules
you know like a drug mule they they move
drugs around the idea is these are
ballot mules uh this is this is separate
by the way from hippo my hippo you know
how they talk about my hippo this is not
hippo this is mule they've identified 2
000 ballot mules
that go and do massive dumps of ballot
harvesting and depositing now it's I I
can I can save you however long the film
is okay the geolocation data they have
they are pretending it's really precise
when it's not a lot of this geolocation
data is very imprecise and it's only
accurate to I don't want to say
specifically because it varies depending
on what data you have it's not
particularly precise in addition the
drop boxes are by definition placed in
highly trafficked areas so the fact that
and remember
they might have started with the
geolocation the in at the imprecise
geolocation data of 50 000 people
and then they go well 48 000 of them
they were they were moving all around
but not that close to the ballot boxes
Here's 2 000 people that we select who
we can argue based on the imprecision of
the data we're going by a lot of ballot
drop boxes now could those people have
been anything right could they have been
doordash drivers and that's why of
course of course it's it's not it's not
worth anyone's time to watch it okay so
for people for from now on if we see the
same user asking 50 times are you going
to be talking about 2 000 mules we're
just gonna ban you
okay it's just it's just it's ridiculous
it's a waste of everybody's time
uh so I've discussed two thousand mules
okay
um
do these people understand ballots are
numbered and registered to a specific
person
uh I you know honestly I don't know what
they understand
I don't know what they understand
so that's that all right everybody
um okay I have my new now that I'm back
uh I do have my updated
um glitches page for my soundboard here
are various glitches I've had more
investigations and Jesse James and Billy
they could
no more Dropbox the Dropbox isn't safe
cephahide we've endorsed JP right JD
Mandel Max silicone a rhino named Mitt
Romney I love that
Obama take a look at the oranges of the
investigation then he went Donald Trump
killed Donald Trump fresh vegetables
truth essential president Donald J Trump
I like for some even though the Donald J
Trump one
isn't Trump it's so good that I can't
help but include it there
um and if I if I'm missing any please
let me know I want to say a huge thank
you to our friend Kevin gouldi Kevin
just signed up on my website and gifted
a subscription that subscription goes to
oh hold on there's a bunch of spam here
uh oh and here's another one that's spam
hold on
let me give this one away to a real
person
Jada Crookshank Jada Crookshank is the
recipient of today's first gifted
membership remember that you can now
gift memberships on our website when you
go over here and you sign up uh you can
check the box
that says this is a gift and then we
will give it away if you have been
wanting a free membership this is we
have only 610 people waiting for
memberships right now okay this is the
lowest it's been for a long time thanks
to so many gifts so if you want a
membership go to davidpackman.com free
membership if you want to gift a
membership go to joinpakman.com and
check the box this is a gift and you can
use coupon codes like for example Obama
Obama which will discount the membership
severely almost too severely
um and that is an opportunity you can
make the moral decision as to whether
you're comfortable with such a discount
let's go to some uh super chats
Valerie says the baby formula shortage
is artificial scarcity the free market
was doing fine but before the government
got involved and started printing
Surplus babies typical government being
the problem thank you Supreme Court yeah
okay very very well done uh Valerie
that's a good one
um June 2020 Supreme Court rules workers
cannot be fired for being LGBT plus
wanted to point this out since you
recently said a few times it is still
legal in some states is this not correct
yeah that was a mistake I did correct it
but maybe you missed the correction for
which I apologize I apologize
when is the next Trump rally event which
we will go live for David I don't know I
don't know when the next one is uh let
me see if I put anything on the calendar
here
uh let's see here
I don't see anything scheduled I'm just
not aware of when the when the next
rallies are
sir I watched the Trump Piers Morgan
interview Trump refused to answer what
is a woman where's the oh is that true
was Trump asked what is a woman
and he couldn't answer it let me let me
look that up that that'd be fascinating
if that's true
Trump Piers woman
oh that's interesting I didn't see that
hold on a second let's take a look at
that
one of the big questions being put to
lots of politicians right now is what is
a woman
I'm not I'm not going to respond to the
question but a woman is a woman is
somebody that swims at a certain time
and doesn't get beaten by 38 seconds by
somebody that a woman is a person that
swims at a certain time wow wasn't even
a good swimmer as a male
one of the big a woman is someone who
wasn't a good swimmer as a male that's
now that's a nuanced description if I've
ever heard one before very very
interesting yeah
uh bizarre stuff David please cover the
disclose act read the wiki intro okay
not right now not right now hey check
this out this person Chris is obsessed
with 2 000 mules David you just skimmed
over a 90-minute documentary you never
watched in one minute and concluded it's
a debunked conspiracy theory you're the
problem no I actually watched the first
two thirds of the film the part I will
admit the the film has about a third
that's just like a panel of people
talking about how terrible voter fraud
is I didn't watch that that part was
trash I watched the part that purported
to be the documentary The geolocation
data is imprecise they're using it to
draw conclusions they couldn't possibly
draw
and the the film is garbage okay now
Chris you've been posting
relentlessly talk about 2 000 meals talk
about two thousand meals now I did and
you're still mad should I ban you Chris
do you just want to get banned
because we have really no use for just
continued
why do you care that I'm not talking
enough about 2 000 mules or not saying
the right thing dude just go just go
should we ban him I don't even know it's
just it's so annoying
moderators pay attention to whether
Chris wants to be banned and just ban
him if he wants to okay it's like that's
it we I the the film is BS
make a channel if you want and talk
about how great it is if that's what you
want to do
man these people
uh okay I want to say thank you to
Michael Howell as well as Luke Beasley
who uh our new members 10 and 11 today
I wonder if that's Luke who's going to
be down in Austin for us hopefully it is
also thanks to Tiffany McClay who just
gifted a subscription and is number 12.
that membership goes to Seth Jacobs Seth
the lucky recipient of a free membership
very much appreciate that and of course
you can sign up on my website using the
coupon code Obama Obama also thanks to
AJ Scorpia for the twitch Prime
subscription you're number 13 today okay
I've got a new uh repeat caller for
everybody this is hold on I have a note
here this is a caller we're calling the
San Diego Scrambler this is the San
Diego Scrambler this is a new caller
alert ladies and gentlemen the San Diego
scrambler
[Music]
foreign
who called in let's see one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen
sixteen Seventeen eighteen eighteen
times do we dare folks do we dare what
do you think
Scrambler is because the ideas presented
are scrambled here it is the San Diego
scrambler
oh yeah [ __ ] report on the case of
the BLM leader Pamela mosa getting voter
fraud checking my reporter Republican
can you vote a frog
and you know you've been the only
blessing forces that say if our
Republicans
that's voicemail number one voicemail
number two
okay how do you call Republicans
Hypocrites for opposing murder and
systems that don't work and say they're
dehumanizing kids by supporting systems
that do work like so you've got three
elements that are really good
unique voice
out of breath and wind noise when they
send capitalism if you're part of
quality of life but you opposed
increase the quality of life because oh
that's bottom
now what about Goodwill supposed to hit
you in the car or how are we gonna hear
us
pretty much the equivalent of denying
Jeff is around yeah are people liking
this this is the San Diego Scrambler
here's another couple
okay
[Music]
was that a truck driving by that's a
that's a good uh audio element
about that kind of being an envelope
in your own video
okay
uh here's another one
Republic at the very beginning the same
Republicans who report who opposed
slavery also opposed government handout
systems
at least they're concise
this is Rocky shackle fruit I noticed
[Music]
kind of early women alleged rape or girl
game they're all credible and we just
turned the capital over something over
that
spots where they'll say hundreds of
women and men who've actual legal party
for lying alleged election workers of
cheating man I don't know what they're
talking about I really have no idea no
clue uh 18 times he called in got to
give him respect for consistency he's
determined Alex says did you see the
trigonometry guys talk about your live
stream talking about your interview it's
hilarious I didn't I didn't uh we could
maybe watch that a little later I know
that they're mad because I said they
were right wing like from my
recollection they told me they were
right wing but not nuts before the
interview started and they said I
smeared them which is weird because I
just said you're right wing I don't know
is that a smear now
thanks to physicist 101 for the twitch
Prime subscription and thanks to Randy
Chavis Randy Chavis or Chavis I hope I'm
pronouncing it correctly who just signed
up at joinpakman.com and his new member
number 15 today we are opening phone
lines after the Press briefing if we get
to 100 new members and twitch
subscribers today very very exciting
let's do a couple more of these San
Diego Scrambler voicemails
are they saying their name is Rusty
shackle fruit I I know them as the San
Diego scrambler
um what do you mean that you lied about
all court cases being thrown out I lied
about all court cases being thrown out
man I don't even know what that's about
I don't know
oh
[Music]
um
all right anyway that's it that's a new
caller I I guess they we maybe they go
by Rusty shackle fruit the name I came
up with was the San Diego scrambler
because everything is so scrambled
Samuel says via Super Chat David I
recently threw out my neck and my doctor
recommended I get a my pillow I laughed
out loud that can't possibly be real is
there really a doctor that if my if you
have a doctor that recommends a my
pillow I would get a new doctor
that's my perspective on that
all right let's look at a couple of
things here uh Congressman Paul gozar
put this tweet out with this video the
men holding rosaries Bibles and wearing
America First hats bravely defending
their churches Against The abortionist
Horde are heroes let's see what this is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
what are these people doing is this
considered prayer when it's out loud
like this
[Music]
[Applause]
then meditating upon these these
Mysteries is the most holes in the
rosary of the Blessed Virgin but what is
this right here this is a there's
summoning is that what this is called
summoning
contain and obtain what they've toward
us
Jesus is this is this Gregorian chanting
loving a sweet Earth
[Music]
[Applause]
are they saying ice cream you scream we
all scream for ice cream
[Music]
we are not your angel
[Applause]
thank you
and a lot a lot of really wacky stuff
happening around the country
uh let's see what else we've got
truck drivers are losing their
businesses because fuel is so high and
Freight is too low Brokers are killing
our business we need help J.R I wish I
knew more about the specifics of what
you're talking about it's it's a I'd
have to research that to be able to say
more about it
sadly we would have we put up with the
same anti-choice crowd here in the UK
just in smaller number
David I just read on the New York Times
that Elon musk's purchase of Twitter has
been put on hold yeah I um I tweeted
about this earlier because I've been
saying for a while this is not a
guarantee
um I said predictably Elon musk's
Twitter buyout is now on hold over
verification of fake accounts did he
ever intend to buy it and actor Jeremy
London who's a good guy said he's
playing everyone he's bored
yeah I don't I don't know
uh oh also some of you might enjoy this
story a viewer once canceled a paid
membership because I said that the
Godfather is a good film and the viewer
said I was irresponsibly glorifying
Violence by saying that the Godfather is
a good film and they they legit canceled
their membership when that happened I'm
gonna admit a lot of this stuff doesn't
bother me
okay when people go hey you know I don't
agree with you about uh taxes so like
I'm canceling my membership it's like
okay yeah that that's fine like that's a
that's just like a political
disagreement and I think it's kind of
silly
if we if you generally like agree with
what I'm doing and think it's valuable
to say I'm canceling because of that one
thing but like okay I I it at least
makes some sense but like
saying that a film is good and it
contains violence so like by saying the
movie's good I mean that's that's real
that was actually legitimately a
demoralizing one it really was
it wasn't a joke no no it wasn't a joke
they were not kidding they within two
minutes they can't they actually
canceled their membership it was crazy
I want to say thank you to guard Brown
for signing up at joinpakman.com guard
your member number 16 today also want to
say thank you to Andrew Culp who gifted
a membership that's number 17 and the
lucky recipient of that one is Dorcas
Zeeman
congratulations we have 617 people
waiting anxiously for free memberships
right now also welcome to Common cider
for uh the twitch Prime subscription
you're number 18 today
other super chats coming in why subject
this to this crap if I wanted to hear it
I'd listen to Fox oh we get callers
sometimes and we play them
uh okay all right that one I already
played for you good here you guys want
to see some cringe I think we have a
little bit of time apparently the I tell
me if this is what I think it is my
understanding is that this is
a right winger named Benny Johnson
please correct me if I'm wrong
showing really great right-wing memes
trying to prove that the right is really
good at satire and mimetics is that what
this is
let's see if it is
yeah Benny Johnson the left Camp meme
okay check out how funny these memes are
[Music]
Folks by the way it is Friday the 13th
and we have
666 twitch subscribers
if we don't end up in hell today it will
be proof it can't possibly exist
666 subscribers on Friday the 13th that
is a wild thing my name is Benny John
and welcome to the world exclusive
premiere of the left can't meme ladies
and gentlemen an exclusive Series this
is an exclusive globalished
internationalist trotskyite socialist
shunlike Obama Trudeau macron and the
rest of these Zio beasts
okay it's on parlor parlor where Free
Speech lives and is champion in the form
of hilarious memes and content that we
are going to be these are hilarious
memes and content I hope you guys are
ready is everybody ready to laugh
highlighting on our show now many of the
memes we will show you on today's
episode would get you banned on social
media why do a show on memes because the
memes hurt their feelings our first
edition meme review the left can't meme
the memes of the week very important
mosque memes so hot right now and the
people at Twitter are like I feel like
I've taken crazy Pals I feel like a
crazy pills isn't this fun guys
here is the Le here's the libs being
fired off like rockets funny that's good
Elon Musk planting screaming limbs into
the field
Libs just want to date Elon Musk
here's Elon just whipping people out of
the the temple that is Twitter
that's really good Twitter's top lawyer
reassure staff cries during meeting
about musk takeover this is really a
profile and courage you know to show
these memes Elon Musk the Netflix
special Elon
that's good very very good always who is
this guy gonna be woke eel Donald make
Twitter great again Elon Musk is Donald
Trump very good Photoshop I'm moving to
Canada I'm removing my music from
Spotify I'm deleting my Twitter account
yes it's always the same thing triggered
Rhapsody triggered Rhapsody very good
Queen reference the triggered people
screaming
yes read the re-rocket yes of course
classic three
where would the meme World be without
the screaming live at Donald Trump's
inauguration where would we be anyway I
think you kind of get the point and
we've definitely had enough uh so that
is proof about how funny that's
considered comedy yeah yeah what's
funnier that or gut felt I don't that's
a that's tough I genuinely don't know
I don't know
someone should subscribe on Twitch the
current number is 666 not a number we
want oh okay now it's 668. thanks to
guitar goddess we have now pushed into
668 and you're number 19 today on Twitch
also want to say thank you to Jared
Frank who just signed up on my website
as well as Daniel lesson you are new
members 20 and 21. also I have two gifts
to give away Tiffany mclea just gifted a
subscription so did Shauna Blackburn
those are Numbers 22 and 23 so a free
membership for Lu uh oh no okay hold on
someone almost got me
uh
the fake ones I'm deleting
Lee Huang gets a free membership and uh
uh let me say
no these a lot of these are fake
and David Lee okay David Lee very good
um got it very good very very important
we should stop calling abortion a
procedure the majority are affected by
tablets no stirrups Etc
right it's not a procedure but so then
what do you say what do we say it is I
guess
thanks to Jay tandoway for the twitch
Prime subscription you're number 24.
we're standing by for Jen saki's last
press briefing as White House Press
Secretary scheduled for nine minutes ago
nine minutes ago
she will uh be departing the White House
and we believe going to MSNBC slash
peacock and or
some people are saying CNN but I don't I
don't really know I guess she hasn't
said for sure
but uh
we would call taking an abortion pill a
treatment a medical treatment
hmm
yeah I'm not sure
I'm not necessarily sure what we would
call it if it's not a procedure
yeah
someone's asking for one more voicemail
from the San Diego Scrambler all right
I'll do one more and then we'll move on
so the CEC have the new dimensional
portals that can see in the parallel
universes
because if they don't the claim that the
vaccine
RNA was saying great with some cultural
injection and prevent fear of Libations
this is something about vaccines right
can anybody tell
I didn't understand that
I just don't know what that was about
it's very strange
MMA vaccines exactly yeah I think it was
about some kind of specific submission
hold you can do with a syringe it was
weird shmob says thoughts on the New
York Times story about the demise of
Conor lamb Senate campaign I haven't
seen it I haven't seen the story
uh uh sounds interesting
but I have not seen it I believe I
believe well so here let me ask actually
Tuesday is the Pennsylvania Senate
primary actually let's get a list of
primaries on Tuesday May 17 2022
primaries
uh 2022 State primary let's see here
I want to put them all up here
oh no this isn't loading now
you've got to be kidding me
okay well all right so the the
Pennsylvania primaries are on May 17th
if we have reason to believe that there
will be live results so we can see
whether Mehmet Oz wins on the Republican
side and whether John Federman wins on
the Democratic side I would stream live
on Tuesday night maybe starting at 8 p.m
does anybody know whether there are live
results for that or whether we have to
wait until Wednesday or something like
that because I that would that seems
like an interesting stream
a list of Elections May 17.
elections calendar here it is
okay
so May 17th okay so we have
two sons special election we don't
really care too much about that Idaho
primary
not super interesting Kentucky primary
maybe a little interesting North
Carolina primary okay the Lackawanna
School District I don't think we care
too much about that
there's stuff going on in Oregon and
then we have Pennsylvania and then we
have South Carolina so really the most
interesting element on Tuesday is
Pennsylvania so anyway the point here is
if there's going to be live results I
would definitely stream
but I I just I just don't know if
anybody knows you can email info
davidpackman.com I will gladly schedule
a stream
if there's going to be something to
watch I guess is what I'm saying
and I don't know whether there will be
oh what else is coming after that so
then May 21st is Virginia
local
and then on the 24th might be another
data stream Alabama primary Arkansas
primary oh Georgia is a big deal so
we're going to want to look at that
and Texas Statewide Primary runoff yeah
so I mean I would stream on the 17th and
on the 24th if there's things to stream
I I just am not totally sure
thank you to tenzen base elevated disc
golf and flea girl for the twitch Prime
subscriptions putting us at 27. also
thank you to our friend Johnny manogue
who just gifted a subscription on my
website that subscription goes to
let's find the next real person
Sam Ford Sam Ford is the next lucky
recipient of a free membership if you
want a free membership requested at
davidpackman.com membership if you want
to gift a membership you do it on our
website joinpakman.com by checking that
this is a gift box and of course if you
don't yet have a membership yourself
what are you waiting for my friends it
is time to do it all right let's do some
so-called normal voicemails normal
voicemails
hey David so with Roe v Wade do you
think the Supreme Court was gonna wait
until after the midterms to announce
that they were going to overturn no they
were waiting until June they were
waiting until June
hey David it's Juan I got two questions
question number one
would you consider unmanning me from
YouTube in the beginning when I first
came across your Channel
I was pretty enraged by all the stuff
going on and I probably said some stupid
stuff on chat
I mean I ask you this because I know
that you don't necessarily support
permanent bands yeah that I didn't even
know that Juan was banned on YouTube I
am fine unbanning Juan I don't even know
anything about Juan's username or
anything about it but sure I'm glad to
unban you and give you another shot
anyway I asked you that question anyway
the other question is
um
do you think it'll ever get to the point
to where
a person in the United States will be
treated
in accordance to who they vote for so
let's say
will Democrats treat
uh some of the votes Republican
in the worst manner or differently
uh I think people already treat others
differently based on their political
beliefs and political or alignment
outside of Washington D.C
is not a protected class so I hope I'm
understanding the question correctly
Juan
hi David my husband and I are hoping you
can help us understand something it's
regarding
um Elon Musk putting Trump back on
Twitter because of quote unquote freedom
of speech why is it that it's okay to
slander and lie and and
um and just create all kinds of havoc on
social media but it's illegal to do that
on paper or in print or you know in
journalism we don't understand that
thank you if you could help we'd
appreciate it I don't even understand
the question you're saying random users
are allowed to do things on Twitter that
a newspaper would get in trouble for
publishing
I think that they're I think I just
think there's two different things it's
like why would
the caller seems to be asking why is it
different I'm asking why would it be
considered the same
not sure I totally understand
uh let's see what else we've got here
hey David uh what's the point of
Democrats like taking the vote to try to
stop the abortion that's just like a
grandstand move the Democrats aren't
going to do anything they haven't done
anything the Republicans have gotten
more done under Joe Biden than the
Democrats have you would think they had
the power what what is their problem
they're they're losers what's the point
just let the Republicans win and try to
block them that's the best strategy
all right thanks you're having you're
doing a great job bye all right we are
standing by for the uh final press
briefing for jensaki I want to say thank
you to Blueberry babe for gifting two
subscriptions and Connor bod for the
twitch Prime that puts us at 31 today
which is a beautiful number
um jensaki we I don't know where she's
going but I believe that she's going to
MSNBC peacock although it's possible
she's going to CNN we we are all
learning together about what is going on
let's see if I have any other quick
voicemail for you
get real dude get real there's a very
powerful voicemail
saying that there aren't enough babies
to go around to people who want to adopt
and I'm yeah that's not true all right
let's listen without some special guests
so I have some with me today
um today uh President Biden is welcoming
Mayors Chiefs of police a county
commissioner and a community violence
intervention expert to the White House
to talk about how the rescue plan is
providing historic levels of support to
make our communities safer the president
will encourage even more communities to
use rescue plan funding to invite more
to invest more in fighting violent crime
and to deploy American Rescue plan
funding to make our community safer as
quickly as possible as we head into
summer as we announced earlier today
over 10 billion dollars has been step
bent or committed already on Public
Safety through the rescue plan including
by over 300 communities and more than
half of the states the money is being
put to use keeping cops on the beat for
community policing investing in mental
health and substance use disorder
substance use disorder Services crisis
responders Community violence
intervention and other programs to
address the causes of crime and ease the
burden on police the these are stories
from across the country about how this
money is already making a difference and
we wanted you to hear about it directly
from the leaders on the front lines
first is Mayor Quentin Lucas of Kansas
City Missouri who has leveraged rescue
plan money to avoid public safety
layoffs and has used it to invest 10
million dollars for new police
technology because of the fiscal space
provided by the rescue plan Kansas City
is also working to hire 150 new police
officers mayor Lucas was elected in 2018
and previously served on the City
Council next is police chief James White
of the Detroit Police Department
together with mayor Duggan chief White
has used over 110 million dollars from
the rescue plan to invest in body
cameras new gunshot detection technology
and 30 million dollars for enhanced
police patrols among other strategies
chief White is a veteran of over two
decades at the Detroit police department
and since he was sworn in last year and
with the help of the rescue plan Detroit
has recorded an 18 percent decrease in
and homicides compared to the previous
year they'll each be briefly will take
some questions they'll have to go to
meet with the president which is a good
reason so I will turn that over to would
turn over from there Lucas thank you so
much
thank you so much and it's an honor to
be with you all today I'm here to
discuss Public Safety Not Just in Kansas
City but in many of America's cities if
we think back just a few years we had a
challenge of tight budgets and Rising
crime the American Rescue plan has
filled an important and vital gap for us
in Kansas City if not for the American
Rescue plan officers would have lost
their jobs salaries would have been
frozen and our city would have become
more dangerous instead we have been able
to invest in a number of vital and
important areas first of all we've heard
much discussion in recent years about
community policing there is no community
policing without the police the American
Rescue plan funds have allowed us to
invest in more police officers and not
only more police officers but salary
increases so that we can make sure that
we are recruiting and importantly
retaining good officers in Kansas City
in addition to that Communications
technology in Kansas City of 10 million
dollars from the American Rescue plan
allows us to invest in so many deferred
technology areas so we can continue to
be smart about how we solve crime keep
our officers safe as they're looking to
solve crime and importantly make sure
that we're spending those additional
funds in areas like recruiting in areas
like intervention as a mayor I've had
the chance not just to have experiences
with my own police department but I've
done ride-alongs and Los Angeles
Baltimore Washington and a number of
other American cities and each of those
you're hearing from people and Mayors
and leaders they're saying that this
support has been key in terms of making
our cities safer and making sure that
everyone in our community has police
officers but has police officers who
have the time and have the opportunity
to get involved in our neighborhoods
each and every day so I thank the
president for giving us this opportunity
with the American Rescue plan I look
forward to our conversation this
afternoon where we'll continue to talk
about how we can work together police
politicians so many other folks in
Washington in terms of making sure our
cities say stay safer rather as we go
into the summer thank you so much
major declaration good afternoon
everyone James White Detroit police
chief I took the role of police chief in
Detroit June 1st of last year after
serving 24 years in the city of Detroit
having gone through bankruptcy in
Detroit uh retiring uh to take a job
with the state and then coming back to
lead this great Department some of the
hardest working men and women in law
enforcement certainly a humbling and
honoring experience for me coming back
and recognizing what's happening in our
country with law enforcement police
Chiefs police departments have to be
Innovative you cannot arrest your way
out of crime there has to be Community
Services Community programming mental
health support and a number of other
different programs having been an
assistant chief at a time when Detroit
went through bankruptcy and knowing what
that felt like I'd much rather be the
chief when there's the type of
investment that we see from the American
Rescue plan for cities like Detroit it's
enabled us to do a number of different
things number one put officers in high
areas of crime put officers around our
city where we are looking at a
statistically gun violence being higher
in those areas than in other areas in
our city but in addition it's to provide
our officers with city-the-art training
being able to develop uh training
protocols based on best practices and
use our training facility and bring it
up to standards that are necessary in
this day and age in law enforcement
making sure that our officers are are
best equipped to deal with the
programming and the issues that we're
seeing in our community one of the most
exciting programs that we have is our
crisis intervention training and our
crisis intervention cars when I took
this role we had Crisis Intervention
officers and three of our precincts I'm
happy to say that today as a result of
the American Rescue plan dollars were
able to put it in six of our precincts
and by the end of the year we're hopeful
that we'll be in all 12 precincts and
what that does for us is provide a very
specific layer of safety not just for
the officers but for the the citizens
who are in Mental Health crisis by
having a trained mental health
professional on that car with a trained
officer who is trained in mental health
intervention recognizing what they're
looking at recognizing what they're
dealing with when they come upon someone
who is in crisis and perhaps engaging in
violence or erratic Behavior it is crazy
how we have a bigger audience on our
Channel than the White House has on
their channel for the same event it's
it's bizarre equipment that we we just
did not have prior to this and one last
thing is is the the training facility
and the opportunity to recruit right now
in policing recruiting is difficult and
having a state-of-the-art training
facility and recruiting opportunity has
been instrumental in what we're trying
to accomplish in our city so with that
thank you
that increases the percentage of Kansas
City's budget that needs to be spent on
policing what's her reaction to the bill
but more importantly what's your
reaction to them uh passing is longer
here on the spirit
I think it's always important to have
locally driven solutions to local
problems I think that's why the American
Rescue plan was so helpful money coming
directly to cities and to state so we
could solve Public Safety problems I I
do not think necessarily that someone in
out state Missouri has better answers
for policing than somebody in the core
of Kansas City and what we've been able
to do both with American Rescue plan
funding our collaboration with Folks at
the state and federal level has come to
Solutions like more officers that my
friends in the legislature and the
governor are asking for and so I do not
support anything that takes away our
ability to work with our local police
department and neighborhood leaders in
terms of how we get to better solutions
for violent crime
this this Administration has often
described talked about funding the
police as crucial to not just lowering
crime but also for police reform
um I I heard uh talk about Crisis
Intervention training but did any of the
ARP Investments That You allocated also
go towards implicit bias training or
programs that require diversifying the
rank and file are acted bystander
training anything that specifically goes
towards accountability or oversight
yeah I'll take that and so in Detroit
we're in a process right now of building
out I've just hired a diversity equity
and inclusion uh director we're
constantly looking at our policies it's
enabled me to incorporate a number of
different components of diversity equity
and inclusion which we already have but
just expanding out and recognizing that
we can make improvements we've been able
to do that
what it came from was the the fact that
we did not lose money or we didn't have
a budgetary shortfall so we're able to
do some things without losing the
dollars uh if we did not have the money
but that's essentially like one you're
talking about a coordinator somebody
that's hired on to you're talking about
really a process because for us uh it's
for all of our officers there's a number
of there's a coordinator and then
there's a programming from that
coordinator that goes out
department-wide and you see that as kind
of the main method of accountability
when it comes to ARP Investments or no
program that enforces no I mean that's
just one of many
um you know when we talk about
Community engagement we can't fight
crime about our communities communities
have to have trust they have to believe
in police officers and certainly this is
a time where police trust is super
important uh and so when you talk about
transparency and policing that's that's
what these training opportunities
provide us to to look at Best Practices
uh to be Innovative and to work on
transparency with Community
thank you um just to follow up on that a
bit going forward in your community and
other communities like yours what do you
think is the most needed underfunded
does anybody know why Peter Ducey is now
wait is that is that Peter Ducey I've
seen him wearing a mask regularly when
other people aren't which doesn't seem
in line with his whole shtick anybody
know what's up with that there was a
reason that both of us have talked about
recruiting and retaining officers we
want officers that actually have the
time to be engaged in communities time
to actually interact with neighborhoods
times to get known by people in the
neighborhood in most cities in America
you're not catching people say we want
to get rid of all the police in fact
I've caught very few people who have
said that they said they want the way
they interact with police to be
different they want somebody who has
time to do community interaction that's
why these investments in my opinion are
so important because then you build up
Community Trust which helps you solve
crime it helps you actually build the
relationships that you need to long term
and so there's not a single kind of
magic program that I think works in
terms of getting to any of these issues
it's instead making sure that you're
investing somewhat holistically in
police departments having enough
officers that you can address things
like having an event at the community
center making sure there are people that
are following up in neighborhoods making
sure that you have social workers and
departments which many of us have and
that's where these funds I think are
largely helping us invest in areas where
without them we'd be laying off police
officers cut in Social programs cutting
everything that's actually needed to get
people to trust the police more
do you have one more Z go ahead thank
you um we're sitting here uh in violent
crime gun crime in particular across the
country it's at an elevated level
heading into the summer we talked about
the the risk there when you go to meet
with the president in a few minutes is
there any specific requests that you
have from him from the federal
government for resources or tools that
your department your city need heading
into the summer sure I mean certainly
you know we we're only one part of the
judicial process right I mean we make
the arrest uh there's our courts uh the
prosecutor's office uh uh you know we
have a number of different needs
um and then there's the intersection of
crime with mental illness and then we
certainly recognize that you know we
have a literacy problem in our country
uh and so there are a number of
different factors that drive crime by
the time someone commits a crime there's
there's a number of fill systems that
has caused that to happen so we're not
going to Simply arrest our last person
and solve the problem we have to do a
lot of work so I'll be talking about uh
those types of Investments
Community Support which we've been able
to do with our ceasefire Detroit and
provide those Community programming
because I think that's super important
mental health is super important
engaging the courts at a high level is
super important and certainly supporting
police officers and making sure that
they're properly trained in some of the
areas that we've talked about today
hey oh here I don't want you to here you
go I'm sorry okay okay
um I just have a couple more toppers for
all of you
um just really getting it all in on the
last day here with the toppers for
everybody the president spoke earlier
today with Abu Dhabi ruler Muhammad bin
Zayed
al-nayan to convey condolences on the
passing of UA president Khalifa bin
Zayed the two leaders agreed to honor
Sheikh Khalifa's memory by continuing to
strengthen ties between the governments
and people of the United States and the
UAE I also wanted to provide an update
on infant formula and where we are and
some updates on steps that we have taken
yesterday we announced a slate of
actions to increase safe infant formula
Supply following Abbott's voluntary
recall the President also spoke to Major
retailers and manufacturers to hear
about what they are doing and what they
need to help increase availability one
of the top issues the very top issue
they asked us to act on was getting
states to increase increase Wick
flexibility so they can get more formula
on the shelves faster basically how it
works now is each state has a contract
with a manufacturer whether it's Abbott
or any of the other manufacturers and
they want flexibility so that they can
if you have if you use WIC and you get
WIC assistance you can purchase any kind
of infant formula this afternoon
secretary vilsack sent a letter to all
states urging them to adopt all possible
flexibilities in the WIC program that is
actually a step we'd encourage them to
do the day following the recall back in
February but some states took the step
and other states did not take the Step
at the time so this is an extra urging
to do that he directed all states to
review their practices and the
agricultural department is reaching out
to States throughout the day building on
months of conversations and next week
USDA will follow up on the letter and
calls to provide states with help to
issue waivers that's what helps
obviously consumers people who have WIC
who are Rick recipients and they go to
the store what we're also doing at the
same time to help create this
flexibility that these menu are these
Supply these store retailers asked for
is today Abbott also committed to
provide critical flexibility to States
through the end of August in the form of
rebates and that means that these states
can plan ahead and they can purchase
Supply ahead from a range of
manufacturers not just the ones that
they have contracts with this means that
families on what can purchase any
available product in the months to come
through August and states and retailers
can plan ahead as I noted the FDA also
just issued a statement about importing
formula from abroad they the FDA
committed to providing additional
information early next week that will
facilitate importation to get more
product on U.S store shelves as soon as
possible and last we recognize that
parents have a lot of questions Mary
asked about this yesterday I think MJ
asked about this too about where to go
and who to call if they cannot obtain
formula right now HHS has just launched
a new web page that provides resources
and places that parents can go to obtain
formula including contacts with
companies Food Bank Banks Healthcare
Providers you can find this at hhs.gov
backslash formula this work is for from
over and in the days ahead you'll hear
about new actions we're taking to
increase safe and formula
we'll give you a week ahead
um on Sunday the president will deliver
remarks honoring the law enforcement
officers who lost their lives in the
line of duty in 2021 at the national
Peace Officers Memorial Service on the
west front of the Capitol on Monday the
president will award Public Safety
Officer Medals of Valor for
Extraordinary Valor above and beyond the
Call of Duty later in the day the
president will welcome the prime
minister of Greece to the White House
where they will affirm our strong
bilateral partnership and celebrate 201
years of Greek Independence the leaders
will discuss ongoing efforts with allies
and partners to support the people of
Ukraine and impose economic costs on
Russia for its unprovoked aggression
after the bilat the president and the
first lady will host a reception in
honor of the Prime Minister on Tuesday
the president and the first lady will
host a reception in the Rose Garden to
celebrate Asian American native Hawaiian
and Pacific Islander heritage month this
month we honor our diverse
Asian-American native Hawaiian and
Pacific Islander communities while the
rich histories cultures and struggles of
the AAA and nhpi communities may be
different their Futures are woven
together through a shared American
experience and finally on Thursday the
president will depart for Seoul with
many of you South Korea for his first
trip to Asia as president Karine and the
team will have more to announce early
next week and National Security adviser
Jake Sullivan will join the briefing on
Monday to preview the trip last thing
um I wanted to just say so I I have one
more topper
um you know this is my last briefing and
it is Brian
um and I wanted to start with a series
of thank yous um
that's myself I wasn't going to get
emotional
okay
um
um thank you um I want to say thank you
to the president and the first lady uh
they entrusted me in serving this role
for the last 15 months and I've talked
about this a little bit before but
during my first conversation with them
which was in November of 2020 after the
election uh I was very nervous when I
went to see them in Delaware and really
what we talked about for the majority of
our conversation was the the importance
of returning Integrity respect and
civility uh to the White House
um the small sliver of of my job here in
in engaging with all of you that doesn't
not mean that we haven't uh let our
Irish side show mine and the presidents
as well from time to time I recognized
that but on my best days and as I look
back
um I hope I followed the example of
integrity and Grace that they have set
for all of us and do set for all of us
every day and I'm incredibly grateful to
them
um I have I'm not going to get everyone
here but I want to thank there is a
Biden family that is extended expanded
far beyond the Biden named family and
that includes people who have worked
with the president and for the president
for many years Ron Anita Bruce Cedric
Kate jod Donald roschetti Susan deese
Jake Evan Annie Elizabeth Alexander
there's so many others will she address
Peter Ducey by name in this in this
speech role is to represent and talk
about the policies of in the work of any
Administration they have integrity grit
commitment to trying even on the hardest
days and worst days to make the world
better for the American people and I am
very grateful uh to them now I'm not
going to cry about the Press team okay
um
thank you to the Press team many of them
are here some of them are not here
um because they are taking much needed
days off it has nothing to do with me
personally I promise but
um you all know a lot of them for those
who don't know them they are incredibly
tough smart hard-working and deeply
deeply good human beings deeply good
public servants and uh you know people
always ask me and I'm sure you guys
could ask this too about whether
Washington is rotten you know whether
everybody is corrupt here and you know
nothing good happens and we all just
argue with each other and I having done
this job believe the absolute opposite
is true because I have worked with and
engaged with all of these incredible
people across the administration and
this amazing team many of whom are here
that I get to work with every day
um and I said as I said about Korean
last week these people are already the
stars of the team but they're going to
be shining stars in the future and I'll
miss them a lot okay I promised myself I
was going to keep it together I'm not
this is the last part of this
um I want to thank all of you in this
room
um you have challenged me you have
pushed me you have debated me and at
times we have disagreed that is demand
accuracy in action that is it working
without accountability without debate
government is not as strong and you all
play an incredibly pivotal role thank
you for what you do thank you for making
me better and most importantly thank you
for the work every day you do to make
this country stronger and I am very
grateful to all of you as well so thank
you for your role and to the role of
your colleagues here and around the
world okay with that Zeke go ahead thank
you Jen um
thank you because my husband is here and
I think anybody who is married with kids
knows that without a remarkable spouse
you would never be able to do it I know
many of you have kids I'm just looking
at Ashley Ed married so many MJ
um and uh he has not only been a
supporter an advocate of mine but he is
an incredible partner and dad and I
wouldn't be here without him okay go
ahead now let's talk about serious
issues go ahead
is there a reason why the administration
waited until uh this week once the issue
is in the public in the library to take
some of these actions that you discussed
is really that website there's a
resources that people might better be
frustrated in the last several weeks a
month we'll see if we have not waited to
take action so what we have done since
the day after recall was announced uh we
actually took steps working with these
producers and working with states to
ensure both one we were pushing States
and encouraging them to expand
flexibility as it relates to WIC which
is again the biggest ask of most people
we talk to and then we've been working
with manufacturers and that has resulted
in Gerber increasing production by 50 on
Ricketts increasing production by 30 and
over the last four weeks more production
of formula than there was in the four
weeks prior and in comparison with last
year this is all work that has been
underway for the last several uh several
months since this recall was enacted on
the website this is a website we saw the
need of course over the last 24 hours as
people had questions and they needed
more information we wanted to make it
readily available and accessible to
people but prior to that period of time
we had not seen obviously what we've
seen over the last few days
has any reaction to the sort of images
out of Israel this morning was really
police beating mortars of zero
journalist American citizen Shireen
including the briefly basket because the
white paint responds and its
presentation reaction in response well I
would say first that we have all seen
those images they're obviously deeply
disturbing we this is a day where we
should all be marking including everyone
there the memory of a remarkable
journalist who lost her life we know
that there is
um we with as disturbing footage and
from the funeral process per session
today in Jerusalem we regret the
intrusion to what should have been a
peaceful procession we have urged
respect for the funeral procession the
mourners and the family at this
sensitive time we're also in close touch
with Israeli and Palestinian authorities
have been and obviously will continue to
be especially given the images we've
seen seeing tweets that the person
yelling is the African reporter who
often asks the really kind of weird
questions that she doesn't know how to
answer
this morning was it was not over the
Press usually the presence meeting so
the farmers
I understand completely it's a it's a
private meeting wasn't meant to be a
bilateral meeting of discussion they'd
known each other for some time
on the issue of the formulations
Simon is the African reporter your
husband for the service as well
Simon if you could respect your
colleagues and other media and reporters
in here that would be greatly
appreciated go ahead
you're gonna have to kick them out right
entire country
an essential no thank you not to the
formula that's not a luxury item it is
an essential it is something that
families across the country rely on is
this such a valuable commodity that the
president thinks that we need some kind
of backstop some ability to Surge in the
way that we do for other essential items
perhaps even some kind of stockpile well
I would say there have been discussion
and some members of Congress have raised
questions say of the defense production
act which that would be something which
is on the table we've not made a
decision about but would be would help
address issues over the long term uh
what we are doing here is we're trying
to be to ensure that states and others
can plan over the long term as in the
coming months but it is uh it is
certainly
um you know a reminder uh that uh not
only do we need to continue to work
closely with manufacturers continue to
work closely with retailers and
providers but ensure that everybody
knows what they can do to get access
over the longer term but I'm not there's
not a discussion of a stock pile what we
need to do is ensure we are addressing
any issues in the supply chain and
addressing any issues with speeding up
manufacturing you might
you imagine how this works sure but how
would that actually work because you say
you're exploring it but it seems that
the issue here is really not having
enough manufacturing capacity so is it
really a matter of just looking for
other sites that can produce this well
that's exactly right Marion so the
reason why it would have a longer term
impact is because the the production of
manuf of a baby formula is so
specialized and so specific that you
can't just use the defense production
act to say to a company that produces
something else produce baby formula it
just doesn't work that way exactly that
is something that could be a
consideration over the longer term and
certainly there are ways that the
defense production act has been used in
other Industries right as it relates to
a chemical that is needed or a specific
tool or part that is needed so right now
of course we're keeping that option
under consideration but our Focus
primarily is on twofold one is
increasing Supply uh making and and the
other is making it readily available and
obviously production is working with
these manual factors and also Imports
making sure we're making more baby
formula available through Imports and
then making it readily available the
biggest step we can take is this Wick
flexibility component which obviously we
took two steps not just pushing States
but also working with Abbott to ensure
they're providing a rebate for longer
term planning
the incident believe that parents should
be allowed to buy formula directly from
abroad
well there have been difficult there
have been limitations on this because of
course we have a very high level of you
know FDA approval processes to ensure
that we have the best formula that is
safe for babies and of course whatever
formula would be imported would meet
those standards but we think the best
steps we can take is to work with Abbott
and Abbott has a responsibility here too
to work closely with the FDA and doing
the steps that are necessary to get back
and operational online we have a great
deal of manufacturing capacity here in
the United so I'm gathering I don't know
a lot about baby formula but if is baby
formula regulated like a medical product
or a food product Michigan that had
tainted formula that killed two babies
but we have a range of manufacturing
capacity here so this import step would
be not forever or necessarily even long
term it's just to address the current
need
go ahead uh thank you Jack and thank you
for your work thank you uh you said
yesterday that the United States would
support Sweden and finland's application
to Nato uh turkey is a current NATO
member and the president turkey is
saying that they would not his country
would not vote possibly on that what is
the U.S reaction to that and will the
U.S intervene on the Nordic countries we
have yeah
um so we are working to clarify turkey's
position we would refer you to the
Turkish government for more information
on their views
um I think there's no question and
you've seen this of from the public
statements of a number of NATO leaders
that there is Broad support from NATO
member countries in Finland and Sweden's
uh you know desire or interest stated
interest in applying to join NATO but we
are continuing to work with turkey and I
pointing to their representatives also
any White House reaction to Elon Musk
saying today that is deal to buy Twitter
is on hold while getting information on
fake bot accounts yes
um
I would say this is a transaction a
potential transaction I guess we can
call it at this point from a private
investor and we don't have any comment
on private transactions our views
broadly speaking on the role of social
media platforms and the need for reforms
certainly still stands but but right now
it's a it's a reported view of a
transaction of a private investor go
ahead thank you Jen for what I've told
is episode 224 yes that is true thank
you for doing this as you've done has
time gone as quickly for you
I haven't been here for all the others
that's true you've been here for a lot
of times a few things back to the murder
of Shireen curious does the president
himself plan to speak with her family
given especially in part that she is an
American citizen
um we have obviously reached out and
engaged through National Security
officials with her family I don't have
any calls to predict or preview at this
point in time but if that does happen we
of course make that information
available to all of you does the
president have any plans to speak with
the Israeli government directly about
the death of the ongoing investigation
well certainly we have been engaged with
them and have offered support and if
they need specific support from us we
will provide that but I don't have any
calls to predict at this point in time
two quick ones on immigration
um there could be a ruling today in
federal court on the future of title 42
and whether or not it gets delayed
beyond the May 23rd deadline okay is a
status report on ongoing preparations
for the end of it should that deadline
hold and how they might change if they
get delayed by by Accord well
um the preparations have been ongoing
led by the Department of Homeland
Security and secretary mayorkas as we've
talked about in the past he has outlined
a plan that he's been preparing since
last fall to ensure we're increasing
capacity at the border that we are
taking steps to ensure that we are
prepared for the lifting of title 42.
those are proceeding obviously I'm not
going to prejudge a Court ruling that
hasn't quite happened yet and what it
will mean or prejudge what the
Department of Justice may do in response
I'm sure there'll be more discussion
about that if and when they roll today
and one other we may remember last fall
there were questions about court cases
brought by families that were separated
at the border yeah and at the time the
White House said if it saves taxpayer
dollars and puts the disastrous history
of the previous administration's use of
zero tolerance and family separation
behind us the president is perfectly
comfortable with the Department of
Justice settling with the individuals
and families who are currently in
litigation
CBS News Review of Court records
published this week however finds that
the justice department is actually
seeking to dismiss all lawsuits filed by
migrant families requesting compensation
over the separations during the Trump
years just curious how
do the Justice Department's move to the
Socialist cases line up with what was
said here last fall and the overall
commitment to Bringing Justice to these
people and as the administration willing
to return to the negotiating table to
try to afford some kind of a settlement
with them since the president among
others has called that policy criminal
it was and the president believes it was
horrific and inhumane uh and our state
our statement made last fall stands now
these are negotiations and discussions
being led by the Department of Justice I
don't have any confirmation of that
report I'd certainly point you to them
for the status of any discussions with
the families go ahead Thanks Jen and
thank you you for always taking my
questions happy to watch your last
briefing thank you from all of us uh so
you must have some information on baby
formula from these manufacturers from
the discussions that the president's
been having
um the administration's been saying that
more formula has been produced in the
last four weeks in the four weeks
preceding the recall and the shutdown so
what is the the best sense of a timeline
for parents on how long this is going to
be an issue and when in-stop rates are
going to get better
well we there's a couple of issues at
play here Jackie and this is a really
important question but it's hard for us
to make an assessment from here what
we're seeing is that the supply
shortages are can be Regional and
sometimes they can rotate and sometimes
the issue at play here is that bigger
manual or bigger retailers have a have a
more streamlined process for stocking
the shelves than smaller retailers now a
lot of people go to stores in their
Community to go buy baby formula uh and
it may just be that there's a bit of a
delay in stocking some of those shelves
it is certainly a good sign and a
positive sign that there has been this
increased production from these other
retailers and our hope is also that
because there's going to be more
flexibility with WIC and the ability of
WIC recipients to purchase different
kinds of formula and enabling many
people who are maybe waiting for their
states to take make that decision and
also that states will have these this
rebate opportunity will provide the
incentive to further provide flexibility
that will also help and of course course
Imports so we're working to to not just
address we've been working to address
for months but we're working to make
this uh ensure that there is greater
Supply consistent Supply on the shelves
as long as possible now what we know and
I know from feeding formula to two kids
is that typically you have one formula
that you give your kid right and so the
challenge here is also for parents when
they're reliant on one formula and maybe
it is maybe their child has certain
needs because they're they're sensitive
to dairy products or other products and
so the other part of this that we're
trying to address is providing these
resources so that if people have
questions about what kind of formula
they can take as an alternative like the
ones that will be imported are not
necessarily formulas that people know
but there may be ones that are parallel
to the formulas that people are taking
or or giving to their children so we are
working on every lever here to expedite
addressing this and to ensure that when
people go when mothers go to the grocery
stores in the coming weeks that that
they will see the Shelf stocked I did
just go through the HHS website that you
guys put out
um one of the suggestions for emergency
situations would be to call uh you know
your pediatrician see if they have
in-store samples or in-office samples or
go to the local food pantry and clearly
you've outlined this is you know there's
gonna be a range of uh
sort of timelines depending on where you
live in the country and where you shop
but say for big box stores I mean the
Walmarts and giant and Krogers
um can you give us sort of a ballpark
window for just realistically how many
weeks or months this
parents are going to be having trouble
finding it or in-stop rates would get
would start to improve let me first say
that the reason we suggest calling
people your pediatrician is because of
this question I just touched on because
when you're feeding your child formula
typically they don't recommend changing
formula necessarily but there are ways
to do it and if your child has specific
needs or is intolerant to certain
certain ingredients a pediatrician can
help advise on that but obviously there
are a lot of other resources through
public health sites as well I would say
for the bach big bigger retailers you
know some of whom the president spoke
with yesterday their number one biggest
ask was the flexibility on WIC and their
feeling was that that would help them
take steps given the increased supply of
these other manufacturers to help stock
the shelves more quickly so you guys
aren't comfortable giving any sort of
ballpark window of time basically as
quickly as possible as our objective
Jackie but it's going to be different
store to store okay and
on the
also on baby formula I think
it seems um you often call in the FTC to
look at price gouging
um I recall this Administration doing
that with gas prices I didn't seem to
really bring down gas prices and did not
increase Supply how's it going to be
different this time around with baby
formula and how quickly are they going
to be cracking down on people who are
reporting and that what are the
ramifications when we're going to see
that play out well the FTC is an
independent agency so by us calling for
them to look at price gouging they
obviously haven't taken a step on oil
companies otherwise you would be fully
aware of it but it is something that we
can all watch even as non-economists and
even as non-oil experts when the price
of oil goes down the price of gas should
go down and that is not what we have
seen consistently I would say as it
relates to baby formula what we know is
that we are certainly seeing and we have
seen hoarding happen and so we are
looking for uh you know that to be
looked into and we think that's an issue
where if there's caps and this is
something we have been working to
Institute on the number of containers
that can be purchased that will help but
also we're we are we are taking every
step we can to ensure that that is
tracked and that can be addressed if
needed to in the pool of doing
everything we can to address this go
ahead and thanks for your service and
thanks for delivering on your commitment
to return the daily briefing all of us
in this room are grateful for that I
want to ask you if I can about crime
that the president's going to be
addressing a little bit later we have
one of the Mayors and one of the police
Chiefs here a short time ago Beyond
directing dollars can you sort of detail
the level of concern with this
Administration about bail reform right
now and about some District Attorneys
being too lenient in their prosecution
of criminals and and I guess beyond that
what other points of Leverage do you
have to encourage stronger prosecution
efforts for any efforts to change that
well I would say first on on bail reform
on the president on the campaign Trail
the president said that cash bail has
become the modern day debtors prison
yeah as many of you you are picking up
on it's possible that Simon ateba that
reporter that was yelling has been
escorted out we there was like a
commotion that you could sense but not
see off camera a little while ago he
made he may be gone we don't know Prime
um we've seen uh We've inherited from
the previous administration the largest
year-over-year jump in murders in record
history in 2020. the our Focus from here
has been putting more cops on the beat
uh you heard the police chief talk about
that through the American Rescue plan
backed up by more federal agents to take
violent crime off the streets cracking
down on firearm traffickers 77 percent
of violent crime in the last assessment
of data we have is a result is with is
with guns to get illegal guns off of our
streets and stemming the flow of ghost
guns something the president has taken a
number of actions on and investing
through the ARP and Community programs
to prevent crime by interrupting
disputes before they spill into violence
I will note and you heard
um you heard the police chief just talk
about this but in cities like Detroit
and Houston who have both used rescue
plan funds to invest in fighting crime
we've seen declines in certain
categories because our view in the
president's view is if you fund and have
more cops on the beat working with
communities that is going to help
address this issue I'd also note that as
it relates to guns which is a huge
concern of ours since last summer we
obviously initiated these announced
these doj-led strike forces they're an
integral part of the president's plan to
keep our communities safe and as I noted
77 of homicides committed in 2020 the
last year we had data were done with a
firearm since the launch last summer at
the doj strike force has already seized
5100 and one of the steps that can be
taken is of course to confirm Steve
dettleback a very qualified person to
lead the Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco and
arms and the president has also called
for an additional 30 billion dollars in
new funding in his 2023 budget to fight
crime and that is a step that he is
hopeful there will be bipartisan support
for a lot of questions in the room so
I'll live at mine to two today the other
one is about asean that's here what
could commitments has the president
secured from the leaders of asean to
condemn Russia well there will be a
communique that comes out later this
evening I know communiques are very
exciting to everyone but there will be
interesting I'm certain in this one um I
will say um you know Ukraine and Russia
would not typically be a major topic of
discussion at asean right you all have
covered them before you visited you've
traveled to cover asean Summits and it
certainly will be a topic of discussion
and was last night and will continue to
be today so there will be a broad
discussion of Ukraine and Russia United
States in these meetings we'll continue
to lay out our approach to Russia's
unjustified and illegal War we believe
the asean leaders are very interested to
hear more about our approach both where
things stand and in terms of the next
steps we accept expect that the leader
statement will also have a reference to
Ukraine in it as well but that is still
being finalized in the coming hours go
ahead
um Will President Biden address the
abortion rally
uh he has no plans to address the rally
tomorrow and secondly does he have any
plans to meet with uh abortion Advocates
uh for rights Advocates at the White
House here we are very engaged with
women's rights Advocates abortions
Advocates and other Advocates as well as
members of Senate members of the Senate
and members of Congress I would note
that this is an issue that is much
broader than abortion Advocates they are
of course uh marching in the streets and
having their voices heard and peacefully
protesting and we respect the right to
peacefully protest but two-thirds of the
country does not want road to be
overturned so this is an issue that we
are engaged very broadly with across the
Spectrum about what steps we are
considering what steps we have the
capacity to do and what we would do if
the final opinion looks like the draft
that was leaked last week the the
families of Americans detained in Iran
have appealed directly to the president
for help in getting them out they're not
they don't seem to have much faith and
or hope that the nuclear negotiations
are
fast so is he is he receptive to that is
is there an effort on going to do for
those people there is an ongoing effort
um led by our negotiating team from the
state department to bring every American
Home who is detained or uh held in a
country and wants to be of course home
with their families it has always been a
separate Channel than the Iran nuclear
negotiation talks it is not in the same
channel but certainly the president is
committed to and will do everything
possible to bring Americans home who are
detained in Iran go ahead uh there's a
question Brittany glider does the White
House have a response on her intention
being expanded yeah there was a report
on that uh this morning
um
so I would say first that Bernie geiners
the American basketball player detained
in Russia development I would just
reiterate that the Russian system
wrongfully detained Miss Greiner we take
our responsibility to assist U.S
citizens seriously and we will continue
to press for fair and transparent
treatment for all U.S citizens when they
are subject to Legal processes overseas
now because the state department
re-categorized her as wrongfully
detained it means that our special
presidential Envoy for hostage Affairs
it's quite a title but a a well-deserved
one is going to be overseeing this case
and leading the effort because it's a
deliberative process and we know from
experience of bringing other Americans
home we're just not going to detail what
those efforts look like at this point
the last question you said that the
president won't participate in any of
the activities tomorrow will anyone from
the administration take part in any of
the protests tomorrow here as an
official representative from the
government I will let you know if
there's someone that we have officially
representing I'm certain that people in
their private time will participate and
attend go ahead after you sit here this
doesn't look to be a lot of appetite
right now for more coven funding in
Congress there have been warnings of
course from the White House but
let's say
is if there is no funding trying to use
their money in the couch cushions to
order the stuff that you said you're not
going to be able to order or win okay to
give us enough when things will start
running out
sure well well I would say there is no
plan B
um well there is you know a limited
amount of funding that we have to work
with it's very limited and it will
require us uh making uh tough choices
about what remaining tests treatments
and vaccines we can get We are
continuing to work the phones hold
briefings make our case publicly of
course as you noted and we are having
bipartisan bicameral discussions about
why we need this funding what the
consequences will be if we do not have
it and those are significant I mean
obviously more Americans will die
needlessly which is the biggest uh
heartbreaking issue we're going to a
exhaust or treatment Supply we'll lose
out to other treat countries on
promising new treatments this is one of
the biggest components that is of
concern to the president and all of us
because as you know how we've approached
this to date is we have ordered ahead so
that we are first in line and we have
the supply needed when there is a better
booster or when there's a better vaccine
or a vaccine that will treat specific
variants and we are putting ourselves
essentially at the back of the line
without this funding yesterday there was
a we hosted a global Summit we requested
five billion dollars for funding for to
help continue to be the Arsenal of
vaccines in the world we will no longer
be able to provide that funding we also
will be unable to maintain our supply of
covet tests and we will be unable to
ensure that there will be in in never
you know an ongoing supply of free
treatments for families across the
country also even cut short previous
orders to either either because you
can't pay for them four because you want
to read out and give them money we will
have to end programs and some of that
will feel abrupt connectivity and ask a
little bit about you know the the baby
formula challenge right now uh
everyone's 401ks are not looking hot at
the moment uh I can't even speaking for
myself
uh consumer sentiment today hit a fresh
uh low 2000 since 2011. it's a bloodbath
in my account but I just keep buying
just gotta keep buying prices are
surging again there's a sense right now
that you know
there's a lot of challenges in the
economy in the US what do you say to
voters if we're frustrated by that and
in particular those who voted for this
President because you sort of promised
to be a sort of capable Steward in
I was sort of the pitch that he made the
book well I think first we would say to
families we understand there are
challenges you're dealing with every day
costs are too high is too expensive to
fill up your gas tank food is too
expensive at the store and our Focus
right now is on taking every step
possible to address those issues we know
that the president that the Big Driver
of this is the was the pandemic and the
impact on Supply chains and the and then
the uptick in the pandemic with Delta
last summer then we had an additional
challenge as you've noted some of these
but with the invasion of Ukraine by
Russia which drove up Energy prices and
that is the biggest driver of
inflationary costs at this point in time
now we saw a lot of questions here what
am I buying total stock market index
fund Total Bond market index fund total
International stock that's it and then
in my rebalancing to maintain three to
five percent crypto well crypto's down
as well so there's really not much but
no I wouldn't do that on a week to week
basis that I'm probably looking at that
more like quarterly just over the last
couple
wearing the price of
uh were also he led the release of a
million barrels of oil through those
strategic petroleum Reserve issued a
waiver for E15 gasoline so thousands of
gas stations in the midwest could have
an additional uh 10 cents cheaper option
at the pump fix the family get glitch he
is Mindful and focused on doing
everything he can to give people
breathing room and lower costs and what
we'd say to Americans also is look at
the alternative we all acknowledge
inflation and cost is a challenging
issue what is the Republicans what are
they presenting as the option
frustrated by this I mean he likes to
see the button stops
things are working is he frustrated with
the circumstances frustrated with his
team is he frustrated he hasn't been
able to get him under control I would
say when you've served as the president
has as vice president for eight years
you're pretty clear-eyed about the fact
that leading the country means that the
buck stops with you and that every
challenge we face is on your desk and
he's very uh aware of that go ahead yeah
you've said that some states have not
done this Wick waiver which ones I can
see if we can get you a rundown that was
not meant to be a naming and shaming
there are some states that just didn't
take that step when the recall was uh
what happened and we encouraged them to
do that in February so today is an
opportunity for the secretary of
agriculture to say now is the time to do
this if you want to make sure that
people in your state who benefit from
guys people promoting services in the
YouTube chat are obviously getting
banned and and she tweeted something I
would read to you but several other
Republican politicians have also gone
along this line she says Joe Biden
continues to put America Last by
shipping pallets of baby formula to the
southern border as American families
face empty shelves she says this is
unacceptable do you have a response to
that well um we do like facts here so
let me just give you a little sense of
the facts on this one there's something
called the Flores statement settlement
which she may or may not be aware of
that's been in place since 1997. it
requires adequate food and elsewhere
specifies age-appropriateness hence
formula for kids under the age of one
CBP is following the law that law that
has been in place and been followed by
the way by the past every Administration
since 1997. so this has been a law in
the United States for a quarter Century
it's been followed by every
Administration and on the but I would
also note that we also think it's
morally the right thing to do uh you
know this is a different from the last
Administration it is the law but we
believe that when children and babies
are babies I should say are crossing the
border with a family member that
providing them formula formula is
morally right and so we certainly
support the implementation of it just
one last question the governors of
Colorado and Massachusetts have sent a
letter to the president
urging him to urge the FDA to hurry up
and consider moderna's application for a
vaccine for children under the age of
five would the president do such a thing
does the administration have any view on
the apparent particular consideration of
That vaccine I would say the parents in
here have a view and we all are very
eager to bring our children and get them
vaccinated who are under the age of five
but science is the president's view most
importantly moves at the pace of science
the FDA is the gold standard for a
reason and we want to ensure that when
those vaccines are available when we are
taking our kids bribing them if needed
to get their shots that it is safe and
we know it's safe but um
as you know the anniversary of George
Floyd's killing is a little over a week
away as a candidate President Biden
embraced some of the messages about
police reform and later he even promised
George Floyd's family that he would get
something done on the issue but now
police reform has failed in Congress
there's no executive order and today
he's basically asking cities um to pump
money into police departments what is
the administration's message for people
who would hope the Biden Administration
would actually significantly perform
policing well first I would say he's
actively considering a police reform
executive order and has every intention
of doing that it just takes some time I
understand that since it was a version
of it came out into the public which
happens back in January it feels like a
long time but these take a long time
there's a legal review of policy review
and he has every intention of doing that
we actually paused because there was
bipartisan negotiations happening and
obviously that was always the preference
because that would make it more
permanent I would say that it's not just
about pumping funding into police
departments it's about Ensure storing
that there are enough cops on the beat
to crack down on violent crime to crack
down on illegal guns that are the cause
of 77 percent of crimes across the
country and what he's also done in the
department of justice has also done is
implemented Federal steps like bans on
choke holds on other steps that the
president would certainly like to see uh
you know implemented across the country
in a part of federal law so he is going
to continue to support the funding of
police he hopes Republicans will join
him in supporting his budget now they
did not support the 10 billion dollars
he announced today because they voted
against the American Rescue plan and he
is uh but he is also supports
accountability and a police reform
executive order will be a part of that
briefly uh what advice do you have for
Korean as she prepares to
seven-year-old you know um
I can I can say we're very transparent
here Brian
um you know I would say that some of the
lessons I've learned that I would I
would tell anyone including Korean
obviously we've had many discussions
about this would be
um one
um you know the best uh the the most
important job that you have in this in
this role I think tied with another one
but I'll get to the point is to project
convey uh the positions the policies the
views of the president of the United
States and every opportunity you have to
speak with him to engage with him to ask
him questions so oftentimes I will tell
you they are questions that you all have
asked me in the briefing room or
otherwise it will make you better
equipped and even more effective because
our job is to speak on his behalf the
second thing I would say
um and in my heart I'm a bit of a policy
nerd but I would tell this to anyone is
that the more you know about policy
issues and the more you can go in depth
on it and spend time digging pushing and
questioning the policy teams the better
able you will be to answer tough
questions to answer the 12th question
and who hopefully provide information to
the public and the last thing I would
say is that it can be repetitive in here
from time to time that's not a critique
you are all doing your jobs but in the
age of social media always provide the
context and all the details because you
never want to be a meme with one line
that would be my treat but otherwise be
yourself in Korean as I said last week
is going to bring her own magic her
Brilliance her style to this briefing
room and always for anyone who comes
after free me or Kareem it's to continue
to make it better and do better for the
president and the in the American people
yes expect um the under green there will
still be daily briefings
I will let her speak to that yes but yes
that is the plan
um go ahead uh thank you thank you Jen
um the the 10 billion that's being
announced today where does the president
of the White House kind of is does the
president see that as something to kind
of celebrate when I look at the original
pool and I realize it's an initial
tranche of 350 billion and I know
there's different kind of competing
priorities here I'm wondering if the
White House sees today as sort of
another call to action to states to
spend even more on police departments or
is this kind of saying is he impressed
by that favor you spend all this money
well I would say part of it is he thinks
that it's important that it has been
spent and he has seen we have seen the
impact of it in some states
um you know that I mentioned Detroit and
Houston for example but part of it is
also about the need to spend more we
know 245 billion is what's been spent to
date so there is more funding left from
the American Rescue plan package and
certainly he thinks keeping Community
safe making sure police departments have
the resources they need is an important
way to spend the money I just have a
quick clarification on them the DPA too
yes that the administration is
considering the DPA for to rent that's
one of the options under consideration
sure I think there's two titles under
DPA one would prioritize contracts and
say companies you need to develop this
another would allow the federal
government to distribute loans to
distribute actual money to companies so
that they can ramp up manufacturing is
the administration considering that the
title of DPA to actually give money
there's also options beyond that about
the use of specific to use there's a
range of ways you can use DPA so I don't
have specifics about how it might be
used I would say that we are already
working and we have been working with
manufacturers to increase production so
that is already effectively happening
and the challenge which I mentioned
before with baby formula is that you CA
you know it's it's
um complex and you can't just say to a
manufacturing facility that makes cereal
you need to make baby formula now so
it's a bit challenging and different in
that regard but it is an option there
are a range of utilities and ways you
can use it and it remains under
consideration that's already happening
it's already happening title three is
already happening no no no we're already
working with manufacturers to increase
production so that's one of the part but
the aspects are one of the ways to use
DPA but we're already doing that
effectively so that was the point I was
making go ahead hey John uh thank you
the FDA commissioner a little while ago
said that um the uh intends to announce
plans next week to help streamline the
import of baby formula into the US is
there anything you can preview for us on
that front and maybe explain some of the
hurdles that currently exist that this
process would be fixing sure well right
now every uh kind of baby formula that's
made in other countries
um is not allowed to be imported here
necessarily so it's it's cutting red
tape and easing those restrictions now
as I noted a little bit earlier what
that may mean is that when moms go to
the grocery store they may see a form of
baby formula that they have not seen
before and they may have questions about
what that is and can I feed it to my
baby that's why we have a range of of
resources and hotlines that people can
call to get those questions answered but
overall what it's trying to do is
provide more Supply so that there can be
a range of options and a range of Supply
on shelves so that mothers don't have to
fear not being able to have a formula to
feed their children I know you said that
the Administration has been on top of
this issue since this issue emerged with
the Apple plant back in February and
you've been working on this issue since
then so can you explain why something
like this in terms of streamlining the
import of products wasn't done sooner
wasn't done before parents arrived at
the supermarket to find empty shelves
well we ex we believe that part of
what's happening right now is that there
was Supply that a lot of the larger
retailers had and it was kind of six to
eight weeks where they had that supply
and they haven't been able to restock it
quickly enough but we would not be where
we are with Gerber increasing production
by 50 percent or rickets increasing
production by 30 percent had we not been
working on this from the beginning and I
would note that what the retailer said
yesterday they need the most is these uh
these flexibility on WIC because that's
where they see the challenges coming up
so that is actually something we did the
day after and something that uh you know
we're continuing to push states to do is
there more you think you could have done
sooner well look hindsight is always 20
20. uh but I would say that we have
what's important to note as as much as
this wasn't being reported on because
people were not seeing shortages at at
the stores as much we did there was an
announced recall back in February right
and there were steps we have been taking
every single day since then the F with
the FDA and the lead to help address any
potential shortage lastly just a quick
follow-up on your comments about uh the
images we saw in Israel today
um you said that uh you just called
these images deeply disturbing of
Israeli police beating mourners who were
carrying this casket you said that we
regret the intrusion do you condemn
these actions by Israeli forces and do
you believe that they had any
justification for actually beating these
mourners and these pallbearers as we saw
I think when we said they were
disturbing we obviously were not uh
we're not justifying them but I think I
will leave my comments at what I said go
ahead uh thank you Jen I wanted to ask
two quick policy questions here on the
house floor uh earlier today the
Democratic Majority Leader saying Hoyer
said well it is unfortunate that in a
time of war that we spend all the time
blaming our own president just a
clarification it's not the White House's
belief that we're at war or we're
engaged in any kind of conflict
I think he's I did not see the full
context of his comments uh what I'm
betting he was referring to was the war
happening in Ukraine so I could see that
Simon attebe was not kicked out for his
outbursts earlier we'll see if he gets a
question hearing economic assistance
we've provided and as I've said before
of course the ukrainians deserve the
greatest accolades for their bravery and
their courage but the American people
also deserve a lot of gratitude for
their sacrifices and their support of
this war
um the president supports the Women's
Health protection act which which did
not pass in the Senate and of course
that would codify Roe but it would also
go beyond that some opponents like
Senator Susan Collins have pointed out
that by codifying a federal right to
abortion the bill would necessarily
strike down some state laws restricting
certain procedures for instance Banning
sex selective abortions and laws that
require parental notifications for
minors seeking an abortion so should we
read into the president's support of
that legislation that he also supports
overturning state laws that would ban
sex selective abortions or require
parental notifications the president
believes in codifying Roe and there are
a range of ways to do that in fact
that's not a answer to the specific
policy question where is the president
on these specific restrictions no one
here doubts the president supports Roe v
Wade and codifying it but there's
allegations to this this proposed bill
goes farther so where does he say the
bill failed the president supports the
bill go ahead yeah
thank you oh go ahead Nadia go ahead not
and then I'll go to you and I go again
ladies here thank you Jen and thank you
for your service and good luck thank you
I have a question and a follow-up on the
question
um the Russian ambassador to Vienna said
today that under a different
circumstances Russia appropriately could
have provided its good offices to the
two sides but not now referring to the
Iran talks and the EU Chief foreign
policy Chief said that it is enough
positivity for the talks to resume do
you believe that Russia is an obstacle
to going back to the deal and
um do you think that there is actually a
chance that we can go back to it well I
would say that our our bully our view on
the deal is that Iran needs to decide
whether it insists is going to continue
to insist on extraneous conditions and
whether it wants to conclude a deal or
not we believe that concluding a deal
would serve all sides interests but
while we have uh certainly condemned the
actions of Russia in Ukraine and their
the the actions of a war criminal in
invading Ukraine uh are the biggest
obstacle to an Iran deal moving forward
as Iran
my police mentioned about sharing I
don't want to emphasize she is an
American citizen yes you know when
American journalists are killed in
Ukraine nobody waits for investigation
they can find their you know hands to
the Russians why Israel get away with
this why not call in for an independent
inquiry
um since Palestinians do not believe
that Israel is capable of
investigating itself I mean this
journalist was fully covered in in the
best in the helmet yet she was targeted
under the ear that means it's a
professional job by a sniper and many
people believe that it was an Israeli
soldier for sure well as we understand
it there are investigations by both
sides we've offered our assistance to
the Israelis to the Palestinians and we
are prepared to provide that should they
want it
uh two questions one um do you have a
comments on the Texas Supreme Court
ruling allowing State officials to
conduct abuse investigations of parents
with transgender kids uh I I've not
looked into the specific court case but
I would tell you that any efforts to uh
to discriminate against to
um to bully to
um you know put transgender kids at risk
would be something we would oppose but I
would have to check out more about the
specific court case on the summit of the
Americas you've mentioned it a couple
times uh invitations yeah it is assumed
that the president of the president of
Brazil are invited uh this guy speaks
super quietly or is that just me
Venezuela
why is it not assumed he's getting
invited quite a mystery there are a
range of conversations going about the
final invitation lists I just don't have
a final conclusion on those and uh as
soon as we do we will make those of
information available to all of you and
then uh just to bookend our time at the
state department I wanted to ask if that
Israel a broader question on how the
president
seems to be the first
um uh in in the modern era not to put
quite an emphasis on uh on solving
Israeli Palestinian conflict he's not
appointed a special onboard for uh the
conflict he has assigned the portfolio
laptop
Administration official what should you
read into that what a priority is it of
his especially as we see these images
to personally get involved in dialogue I
would say first as it's always been the
case any Envoy would be working out of
the state department it was the case
when I was at the state department and
we knew each other there and certainly
you've seen the Secretary of State and
also the president talk for decades
about the need for a two-state solution
how that is the only viable end uh way
to end
an ongoing conflict in the region and I
would certainly say that remains his
view remains his policy and but I would
point you the state department for any
updates on negotiations or engagement go
ahead I have a follow-up on working
grinder
um does the president have plans to meet
with Brittany greiner's family like he
met with Trevor Reed's family we are in
touch with uh with her family
um but I don't have any uh planned
meetings to preview for you at this
point in time and then I have a
follow-up on title 42 sure I know a
judges really hasn't been made yet but
it does
temporarily delayed title 42 from being
disability Administration plan to appeal
that that would be an announcement made
by the Department of Justice one more
question just regarding that you know it
seems that the divided Administration
has been challenged by the court several
times on you know immigration efforts
that they've tried to overturn from the
previous administration I guess what
concerns that does the administration
have that this will continue as you know
immigrant immigration is pretty much a a
pretty big policy you know that the
Biden Administration and President Biden
himself has said that he would try to
overturn some of these policies that
were implemented under the previous
administration I guess how does the
president feel about some of these
sort of roadblocks that the
administration keeps hitting um you know
with
judges in the courts um not allowing or
further delays I would say the biggest
roadblock is the fact that the president
put forward an immigration bill in his
first day in office and we haven't been
able to move it forward and there have
been efforts to move it forward through
the Senate through the reconciliation
process there have been efforts to try
to engage uh in a way we're very open to
engaging have been very open to engaging
uh it was like a lot of our callers
aspects of his proposal many aspects
that should not be controversial at all
you know the uh the effort to invest in
smarter security to fix our broken
Asylum processing system those are our
biggest obstacles and what is deeply
unfortunate is that the need to
implement immigration reform to fix a
very broken and outdated system has
become so political that there's an
unwillingness to engage from the other
side on what Solutions uh should be you
know we can work and work together on it
wasn't that long ago when there were
bipartisan bills that were being
discussed and even almost passing
Josh's question here um you know CPI
inflation is 8.3 uh we know it's hard to
get baby formula gas and diesel fuel is
now record prices again today um how
staffers are getting free Peloton
memberships among the pole says well
there's a lot packed into that list
there you have I don't know how it's
related oh yeah it is appropriate it's a
wider view a Monmouth poll shows that 79
of Americans believe the country's going
in the wrong direction so my question is
is the president as the head of the
country as the head of the democratic
party out of touch economically with
Americans
well there was a lot packed in there and
I'm not entirely sure the root of your
question but I will do my best
um I would say first the president's uh
top priority and you heard him say this
okay that was like a lot of my callers
questions is that fair and he laid out a
specific plan to do exactly that and he
has taken a number of steps that would
to do exactly that including lowering
the cost of the internet ensuring we're
taking every step we can to bring down
the cost of gas taking steps to ease the
supply chain something's been working on
from his first day in office and he has
proposed and advocated for and continued
to fight for a Reconciliation package
that will lower significant costs for
the American people I would say the
contrast here is what the other side is
offering which as you've heard me say
many times but it's worth repeating is a
plan by chairman Scott that would raise
costs on 175 million Americans who make
less than a hundred thousand dollars so
I would say for the American people what
they can know and understand is we all
agree inflation is an issue we all agree
costs are too high the question is who
has a plan to address it put on gas
specifically the interior secretary
testified before the House
Appropriations Committee that there was
no plan to go forward with a five-year
plan for oil drilling in the Gulf they
need that plan in order to open up
leases down the road for that um we've
seen we saw the department of interior
cancel a lease sale so are there signals
you know to bring down gas prices well
we know the department of interior uh
made quite clear that they canceled the
Cook Inlet project because there was a
lack of Industry interest that's not
actually the issue the issue if we take
a step back is that Leasing and
production offshore is a lengthier
process taking up to 10 years Mo a sec
more of the more than 10.9 million
offshore Acres currently under lease
industry is not producing on 8.26
million Acres that's 75 percent that is
non-producing of the 24.9 million
onshore acres and release Industries now
producing on 12.3 million that's almost
50 percent and they're almost 9 thousand
onshore permits the issue is not permits
there are plenty of places for oil for
oil companies to drill on they're not
that is the issue go ahead thank you
okay go ahead Patsy thank you Jim thank
you for your service and good luck for
your next thank you all right guys I
have five minutes until I have to record
an interview for next week so I'm at the
end of uh the time I had allocated this
is going much longer than expected I
guess because it's her last press
briefing but I need the studio I need
the room to get something recorded for
next week so we will end our coverage
here I may be here this weekend but it
seems the Trump rally won't be live so
more than likely our eclipse from Luke
who's going to be on the ground there
will be on the Monday show
and
um some really great uh stuff coming up
next week by the way and I will probably
be live Tuesday night with Pennsylvania
results assuming that they will be live
with those results but I just don't
really know the answer to that all right
so lots of things coming up thank you
for joining me